[Musique]
oui je suis célibataire jamais je ne
suis pas un chien
écoute agathe je ne suis pas sur
instagram mais je te proposera un suivi
mutuelle tu veux me suis je te suis tu
me soit le rouge de fallen
sa manière vraiment énervé c'est à dire
que dès que tu sens dans la rue faire un
cycliste qui s'énerve sur un taxi qui
s'énerve sur un piéton donc si c'est un
espèce de voile avait joué innervé tout
le temps
[Musique]
non moi la chanson que j'adore c'est
larusso tiouka
est un cadeau pour noël le livre de
groupe zen ce gang 50 conseils pour
réussir dans divers un pub du blog est
un cadeau à faire quand on ne sait pas
quoi offrir à quelqu'un c'est le cadeau
idéal
je ne saurais que te conseiller